all right bobby
bobby where'd you girl where are you
from originally um well i was born in
east los angeles um white memorial
and um
then from there we we uh
we moved out to armani
california
for about the first maybe i say
three years of my life
um
and then we kind of wrote you know
gravitated towards the city of pomona
yeah and i've been there since so you
grew up in the eastern suburbs of l.a
but yeah pretty much pretty much done
that way what uh what was your family
like
family was actually
i mean it was it was great you know mom
dad was there um
i got
two brothers and a sister and uh we
we've been pretty
close for the most part you know uh
just never went through any
uh you know mom and dad fighting
anything like that um
it's pretty good you went through high
school yeah i went i did high school um
you know obviously you know i got
incarcerated pretty young
but um yeah i did i did i was a straight
a student
you know a
baseball program
you know all through high school junior
high so you started with the
jail or prison what i started well i
started obviously you know
uh juvenile hall then why a then you
know county jail prison but i started
pretty young
13 yeah i want to say i caught my first
uh my first you know trip to uh to lp
right here now so so the gangs are are
strong in pomona as well oh yeah yeah
they're pretty uh
they didn't go back a long time
you know
this is the mexican gang yeah well it's
it's it's the city's pronoun it's pretty
much
black and hispanic so we have
it's pretty
you know down the middle um we got a lot
of hispanic gangs a lot of uh a lot of
black gangs that's pretty much it but um
but it's real it's real heavy down there
it really is when you when you were a
kid did you feel like you had options
for you or was it just oh absolutely
like i said i was always i was always uh
um
i was always good i was good at school
um i had something to do after school
you know so i was always
uh i always kept myself busy and then
if i wasn't in that school or if i
wasn't at a practice or anything like
that i was always following my dad
around uh
because he used to work multiple jobs so
i was down here in l.a with him working
[Music]
he would travel and i'll go with him you
know follow him along but i had options
you know
i just chose the path i chose because i
mean in all honesty
i liked it i gravitated to it you know
uh
it caught my interest you know and um
you know i know a lot of people say that
uh
you know they they do it because they
they had a they come from a broken home
or or um
that's a common story yeah that's
usually what you hear you know and or or
uh or the drugs or
or something like that but for me it was
just really the
i seen a spotlight and i
ran straight for it
anybody explain to you that it might
might mean a lot of time in prison or
death
no absolutely uh i mean everyone
any real gang member will get that talk
before joining uh uh
any neighborhood you know and if they
don't get the talk then then there's a
problem there you know but usually it
goes you know
you know what you're doing you know
uh there's no there's there's
this is only gonna end very few ways
it's either gonna be jail
the ground
yeah very few actually make it
uh
you know old to see their their old age
you know
and um those are the lucky ones but you
you you proceeded anyway i still went
through it yeah i i like i said i i
gravitated towards i liked it i seen
that
you know for me it wasn't uh you know
people do it for the wrong reasons i
think you know some uh they do for the
girls that's that's one of the big the
big answers the girls you know
i mean if you can't get girls on your
own you're not gonna get girls if you're
a gang man be honest with you you know
but uh
or they do it because you know they feel
like they're a part of something or
something like that
and i just i i just i wanted a yang bang
be honest with you you know what what
kind of stuff are you guys getting into
well i mean
we're we're a typical mexican gang so
you got your your you know you got your
car thieves you got your your robberies
you got your uh
you got your shooters your drug dealers
you know
and um
so you we got everything i mean
you know the list goes down yeah how old
are you uh i'm 34. 34. so the drive-by
era were you around for that i was
around for the end of it the end of it
so i have i i was i witnessed the um
i was able to witness it
um it was ugly you know
uh
it it um
it was a lot of innocent people that got
hurt during that time and and it was
it's uncalled for you know i'm all for
what we do i'm all for if something
happens to me i know what i signed up
for
you know
but uh for a kid to get hit or for a
grandmother or grandfather or something
like that that's that's
that's out of line you know are you the
only only person in your family to join
again yeah
yeah i got uh my thankfully my my
brothers didn't follow my my footsteps
and uh
and uh my dad wasn't involved my dad's
what'd your family think of it
i mean
i it was it was it was a little hard you
know um
mom and dad would go look for me every
night you know i would sneak out the
window and and run my homeboys and and
hide out
and and sure enough nine ten o'clock
you know here comes mom here comes dad
knocking on doors where is he at where
is he at until they grab me by the ear
and take me back as soon as they go to
sleep out the window again you know
but um it was hard man it was it was
real hard
it got to the point where you know
obviously as as time went along
uh
you know when crimes went along with it
you know i started bringing pistols home
so you know mom would search my room and
she'd start finding them
and you know obviously she would take
them
get rid of honestly to this day i don't
know what she did with those guns
um
and it was a few of them
but it got to the point where she just
got tired of finding them you know and
then not only that but a lot of my
homeboys started just she kept seeing
the
t-shirts with the faces on it you know
and i think she didn't want to see my
face on any of them so it got to the
point where she didn't throw the guns
away she would take the bullets out
and tell me just get rid you know don't
let their brothers find it and and and
i'm not saying that she condoned it in
no way straight performance my mother
ever condoned anything like that
but
i think she just loved me so much that
she she didn't want anything to happen
to me
you know
and um
what is it that
draws a young man to this lifestyle
it's it's a lot of things i mean like i
said for me was it was a little bit
different i know i know like you said
most most guys are just looking for a
family and that becomes their new family
yeah that's that's but there's there's
something about the
um
well it's almost like a right of manhood
for it's
yeah it's like yeah write a passage
almost you know like i mean from
you know back in time you got you know
from from the tribes and and things like
that yeah it's always been uh um you
know as you as you as especially the
males you know as you grow
you you have to you kind of go through
those steps
and and and um it's a tribe yeah it's
it's so it's basically the same thing
you know back then they were they were
obviously they would fight for territory
you know to expand and things like and
we're basically doing the same thing
you know uh um
you know maybe some people might take it
a little
uh
further than that and and and um
you know when you bring in the drug
dealing and all that but for the most
part that's we're always fighting for
territory and we're always trying to
expand we're always trying to recruit
you know and we're trying to recruit the
best of the best we don't want no
obviously we don't want no uh
you know guys that ain't going to
participate if that's how you want to
call it
how many years have you done in prison
well i i i mean
i went in i caught my first term at uh
the age of 15.
um
i caught a uh
it was attempted murder and got dropped
down to uh i played uh a plea bargained
for uh assault with a firearm gang
injunction is what really screwed me
um but i caught
15 years for that case
at 15.
and then um during my prison stretch i i
caught two more years on top of that so
i ended up doing 17 flat for things you
did in prison um
again the list goes on you know
i um
well you know because the gang life in
prison is it's it's it's it's a lot
different
a lot different a lot more
structured
a lot more unified
um
which is which is ironic because
you know you you have you know us
growing up out here going against each
other all the time you know
uh mexican against mexican or against
black or whatnot
and um
you know you get to the you know to you
you progress until you get to the county
jail it's prison and and the same guy
you shot at
same guy you're having dinner with you
know
or or the same guy that's gonna have
your back if something happens but it's
more racial in there you know
so
it's
it's
when you when you first land into prison
it it's it's um it's a little hard to
kind of get used to because you're
you're used to
you're programmed to you see a certain
tattoo or you see a certain and all your
your program you know you want to you
want to go ahead and attack or you want
to
you know you want to start dissing them
or or whatnot
and um
[Music]
so you know
you get chewed out a couple of times
because obviously you slip up or when
you you let it get to you sometimes
they'll pick on you if they're older
they'll pick on the kids just to see to
test them
um
but honestly if if if
if i could choose either or as far as
like
would i rather gang bang on the streets
or would i do the prison gang
um
i was forced to grow up a lot faster
especially in prison i went in young
and i was i was i mean i had no choice i
was in the big leagues now so
uh there was no excuse
you know i i couldn't say i didn't know
i couldn't say uh um
you know i'm sorry or or i'll take it
back or you know i'll do better next
time it wasn't all that in there you
mess up it's it's uh
there's there's risks there's uh
you know there's there's the
consequences
so
you have to pick it up very quickly
um
but honestly i
i i learned a lot
also i i uh
if i didn't go through all that i
wouldn't be become you know be the man
that i am now
and uh in no way shape or form am i a
good man i don't i i don't believe that
um you're still i still have my flaws
you're still active i'm an active gang
member still um
and and uh
i'm not as as reckless as i was as it
was when i was younger
by all means i'm not i'm not that that
you know
um you know i got kids you know
and but i am still
you know you show up to the city and you
ask you know hey you guys they'll point
you automatically to point you in the
right direction it doesn't matter where
in the city you stop
don't know where to point you you know
and to get to that point to where
i don't need to
let people know where i'm from or who i
am anymore
is where
any gang member wants to get you know
and um
i can say i'm fortunate enough to have
gotten that
some people might look at it as this
that's not something to be proud of i
bet differ
you know
um
to come out after all that time and just
try to change my life
at this point
would would be um
in my eyes would be a complete waste of
17 years you know
i i chose this path i chose this career
basically so i'm i'm going to see it
through you feel like you've built
something you don't want to give up on
exactly you know and and um
and i know it's going to lead where it's
going to lead you know or what the
possibilities of where it could lead to
do you think you'll be back in prison
again
well i've been back you know i i went
back yeah i went back uh um
recently i went back in in um well i
paroled in 2017
after the the first stretch
and then uh
in
2018
the ending of 2018 i went back for uh a
year flat for a pistol case
and um
[Music]
and you and the thing is that
do i think i'm going to go back i mean i
hope not but uh yeah i mean chances are
i i i am you're doing things that might
get you back yeah you know
of course
however do i want to go back
absolutely not because you know you'd
rather be free well it's not
it's not you know here's the thing is
that
there's been times where it's it's been
hard out here sometimes i'm not gonna
lie you know um
trying to cope
after all that time
it's been a little bit difficult you
know
and um
that's all i've known i've
i grew up in there you know
my whole youth my teens my my early
twenties my prime years i did in prison
all i know is prison
you know you throw me on any yard and
not program like that you know i'll tell
you
i can i can i have a you know
peripheral vision of everything that's
going on in the yard i'm i'm i'm savvy
to it you know but out here i get
overwhelmed i get uh
i get uh
almost um
like shot you know uh um the crowds i
can't do crowds i can't do big buildings
still
um
because i did a lot of uh most of my
prison time i did in the shoe you know
uh oh so you're isolated i did i did i
did 11 years isolated in there and um
a lot of people won't admit it but that
place really screws you up man it really
does and i didn't know that until
getting out you know
i realized
how what that place really did to us you
know
because in there we we we we um how can
you say it we we adjust you know to our
surroundings so even even on the streets
free for how long now um
i've been out since uh for
uh going almost close to four years i i
believe
with giving a couple violations in and
out of the county jail you know three
months here uh 10 day flashes what not
but um
yeah for you know three years old
something like that
and um
but um
i still haven't done anything you know
it's it's like uh there's still so much
i want you know in there you you think
well i want to do this when i get out i
want to do this when i get out
for me it was it was just
getting out there traveling you know i
wanted to i i i always thought that i
would go and see
i'm not going to say the world you know
because i mean it's a little far-fetched
have you left california oh yeah yeah
i've i've been uh nebraska mississippi
uh new mexico arizona nevada you know
oregon
but uh i'd love to see new york you know
yeah but let's let's say you grew up in
wisconsin for example
your life would have been very different
absolutely yeah absolutely yeah the the
surrounding california is is just
this is so much different man it's it's
i mean you you're i mean you're chicago
right i'm from chicago yeah well chicago
was actually pretty active yeah i don't
know
that's that's why that's why i didn't
say so yeah we're not going to go use
that as well
you know it's just um like for example i
went to nebraska
you know nebraska when i went to
nebraska as soon as they found out i was
from california i forget it i mean they
were just all over you know like it's
just
the lifestyle
people people um
they want to know what it's about they
want to know you know like it's like it
gets glorified exactly yeah exactly like
the gang like the gang lifestyle for
instance
and you know i don't know how how hip
you are to it but japan has a big
gang um
style going on right now the real big
the lowrider scene um you go to japan
right now you'll see you'll see a
neighborhood full of
you would think there's a bunch of
mexicans out there gangbang you know
it's just
something about our style just it it it
it captures people's attention it
captures interest it's an interesting
cultural phenomenon you know and and um
and they're so
late
like they're barely catching up like
they're still dressing like we were
dressing back in the 80s you know with
the khakis and all that i mean i still
dress that way i'm just i'm stuck still
there you know in my mind i'm still i
still think i'm 15. you know
because time stopped for me you know
once once i went in
um
so it's just uh
like i said
it's it's it's a lifestyle that you know
given it's it's not
for everyone it's not um
you know a lot of people get hurt i've
lost a lot of homeboys i've gotten hurt
myself you know unfortunately i've never
been shot or anything like that but i've
been shot at you know and for anyone
that hasn't been through that i mean
it's not
it's not a it's not something you forget
you've done some shooting i assume uh
i'm sorry you've you've done some
shooting as well well yeah i mean i'm to
say i haven't i mean
you know are there any things that you
regret
um
no
i really don't i mean
everyone that's i've never i've never
done anything to where anybody that's
not part of this lifestyle has gotten
hurt
so with that said
everyone knows what they signed up for
i know that at any point i can get shot
by another gang member so they should
know the same you know so no of course i
don't regret anything i've done
i mean maybe maybe i mean you know maybe
signing the deal i signed to go to
prison i regret that
i think it was a screwed up deal but um
i accept my cons you know i i take
responsibility for my my actions so
yeah and your
how much time have you spent with your
kids
done
done i went in
when i went in i i
when i went in i didn't know she was my
at the time
the the girls i was dating i was
pregnant
until six months
into my sentence
she had gone to my mom's house and and
to tell her like
this is your grand you know
so my mom went to visit me in juvenile
hall and told him just gave me the
sonogram instead
there you go
i didn't believe it i was like
it can't you know but sure enough the
moment she was born
many me you know it was me
there's no point in taking a test or
anything this is
it's my daughter
and uh so i i got to see her
for the first maybe year of her life to
where my she would go take her to see me
in prison by then i had already hit you
know the prison main line she would go
visit me for the first year
and then unfortunately i caught my my
shoe term so i got validated which is
basically the
the prison gang uh
the prison gang uh
officers or whatnot um
they do their uh they do their
investigation and then
whether
what they've their findings they'll um
validate you which is basically for your
gang ties or your prison gang ties which
is completely different to your street
gang ties
um
in my case it was um
you know uh
for the mexican mafia you know and um
now
it's all allegedly
but
i did get
you know convicted per se of it and and
and i did get validated so that's how i
got sent to the
to isolation into the shoe
for the you know for the next 11 years
but um
um
it's just uh
when i caught that
visiting is completely different from
general population obviously general
applies you get the contact you get to
spend you know six plus hours with your
family and and eat with them and
interact with them and hold your
daughter and all that
lovely i mean compared to in the shoe
where it's behind glass and it's for an
hour
and that you're lucky if you get that
and that was all because you were
connected with the most notorious and
gang in the world and and basically
because of of of
of the the threat
that i posed to the institution
um because of those ties um
i i lost not only you know
my the little freedom that i do get
in general population but you know i
lost my my privilege to see to hold my
daughter and see my daughter grow up
because
now i you know
unfortunately none of the shoes are
anywhere down south where i'm from
they're all up northern caught you know
california which is 18-hour drives and
all that and my family there's no way
they can make that
so unfortunately i didn't get to see my
daughter again until i paroled since she
was 17 by then
so
16 year gap the mexican mafia seems to
be getting stronger and stronger as time
goes on right
i mean it's been around for a long time
you know yeah but unlike the mafia which
is fading away it seems
well it's it's it's
the mexican the italian mafia yeah no i
i i it's it's uh they had a long run
yeah
they're they're very long they're both
very notorious but but the mexican mafia
just seems like it's
you know what it is it's um
they're very influential you know
and um
for a young man
fresh in
glorified you know lifestyle and that
that's what we
look up to that's what we aspire to
exactly so
of course they're gonna
of course they're gonna gravitate
towards that you know what can i do for
you or anything like that and um thus it
grows yeah it isn't something you run
away from it's something you absolutely
you dream about
you know when i when i finally hit you
know i i went i went through the shoot
process so i went to hatch b corcoran
when i hit you know pelican bay
i was fortunate enough you know and and
as as
as uh you know weird as that sounds for
someone to say fortunate enough to land
anywhere like that
i happen to land in the short corridor
of pelican bay which is uh
where they're all housed
and um
so
i got to know you know
i was where where any game i don't want
to be you know i was in college now
and know the big leagues
oh yeah
you know
and um
i got to meet
some
very interesting people not only
my my uh elders per se you know the
northerners the
the aarons
you know
uh
the blacks you know and um
very intelligent man
extremely intelligent
um
i think you're talking to lawyers you
know businessmen
never think you're talking about yang
member
uh completely fool anybody
you know
and um
how could you not want to
be a part of that you know
how could you not want to um
have the respect
you know that uh
the power
you know
so
uh
if if you if you get involved into this
lifestyle and you're really really
involved or you're really serious about
it
that's what you want to get to that's
where you want to go that's what you
want to meet that's what you want to be
now whether you're going to be or that
or not is you know only time can tell
and that's really up to the person you
know um
but
yeah i mean to answer your question yeah
they are uh they are growing
and i'm pretty sure they will continue
to grow yeah is there any getting out of
the gang once once you're in
which as far as the street game um
yeah
in a box
i mean we're gonna lie to you you know
it's uh
yeah
as the saying goes it's blood and blood
out you know
i mean they're not just going to let you
you know go ahead be on your way
no you know too much
you know
you've how can you sit there and build a
a trust uh
build a bond with us and then just wanna
that's disrespectful
that's a slap in our face
we invested time in you
how can you just walk away
it's not going to happen
you know
i mean at least i've never
is the integrity of
the gang members today as
as strong as as it once was absolutely
not yeah it seems like a lot of guys are
informed it's it's it's so washed down
now
you know
don't get me wrong you still got your
you know some of these kids out here
knuckleheads you know you put a pistol
in their hand they're shooting 150
rounds into you know probably a hitting
nothing but
they don't hesitate you know these kids
are um
it was a lot harder to get
guns back then than it is now or or the
quality of guns you know back then we
ever
you know you'd be lucky to get anything
with a clip in it you know
now you got drums and all kinds the kids
running around with you know skinny
jeans and big old rifles you know
and uh
it's but it's but it is
how can i say the respect's not there no
more the the loyalty you know
and a lot of that has to do with
the family the family bonds you know a
lot a lot of these older neighborhoods
were
family based
cousins brothers
nephews nephews whatnot
so
or friends of friends you know so in in
one way shape or form
we grew up with
each other we know each other we know
their parents we know their girlfriends
we know their kids we know uh
everything about them where they sleep
where they go to school where they [ __ ]
you know
uh so
it's it was a lot harder for
people back or us back then
to turn on one another then it is now to
where you got outsiders coming in
who
we've never even like where did this guy
come from
but he's claiming our city
and they allow me uh something happens
he's the first one to point fingers you
know like of course he's gonna point
fingers either he has no ties to it he
has no he didn't grow up with us so he
doesn't care you know
so in that rep you know in that aspect
of it it's it's not the same you know
it's not uh
it's nowhere near the same than it was
back then
you know um
everything just even even dealing with
with with law enforcement
you know
there was a respect back then you know
they knew what we were doing and we knew
that they had a job to do
so
we weren't going to disrespect them
because they put the you know the cuffs
on us we know what we're doing we know
what the consequences are
um but now you got you know so i get i
get officers that that'll pull me over
and
and they they've known me throughout the
years you know
so they know what i'm out there doing as
well and uh they'll pull me over and
call me by name you know they'll be like
a suspect you know
uh
these these kids man you gotta come you
know talk to these kids man because
they're disrespectful you know
they're like i talk a lot of [ __ ] yeah
so i'll have to go and and not because
not i'm not doing it to favor the law
enforcement you know there's still that
there
um
i'm doing it because it's it's something
bigger you know there's no need to
disrespect these men for doing their job
i don't believe
um i've never done it
and because of that they don't hassle me
like that or they don't uh
they don't
pick on me what you know so and that's
the speech i would give to these kids
it's like you look you
you get you get you get rolled up on by
these these cops what every day you know
through sometimes three four times a day
why because you talk a lot of [ __ ]
you know
you want them to stop you shut your
mouth there's no point you know you call
them a [ __ ] then you jump the one run i
mean what's that gonna get you if you're
gonna call a [ __ ] at least stand there
and let them pull up then tell them to
take off their badge and let's see if
they do it i guarantee you 80 of the
time they'll take off that badge you
know i've seen it they've done it before
you know and uh and you'll learn and
then just do some training for a reason
because they'll whip your ass
but uh you know the respect's not there
man it really isn't
you know and i wish it was
because it would make me
you know it's not it's not deterring me
from from being involved still that's
not going to change you know i am who i
am
you know i'm proud of it um
not going anywhere you know
um
however you know
it does kind of make me
you know kind of
sigh you know and whatnot you know like
kind of like feel bad about what it's
what it's
become
you know
before i remember i would
i would die to just be in my our park in
our neighborhood you know i would do
anything the first chance i got i would
just skate just to go and hang out at
our park with all our homeboys you know
because that's just what we did we that
that was that was it was fun it was uh
it was our after school activity it was
our
our uh it was our everything you know
and now i pass by our park and i just
sometimes i don't even glance at it
because it's just not the same you know
to catch maybe
two three
of us out there now
compared to back then when you pass by
then you catch 35 of us out there
it's a big big difference big gap you
know
it was a lot easier for us to get shot
though i mean you got a big crowd of
course you hit somebody
you know but um
it's it's uh it's a lot different
a lot different
bobby what do you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
how to be loyal
loyalty
to me loyalty is so big man
and it was a big lesson in prison
and it's been a big lesson
coming home
and i'm not saying loyal to the gang or
anything like that i'm just saying
loyalty and
you know
for what it is you know to to anyone you
know
for example if you give me a hand you
know
that shows me a lot especially if you
don't know each other
you gain loyalty or trust
you know
um the little things the little things
that count you know and loyalty is just
so big and it's
such a lost
thing you know you know
it's loyalty
all right bobby thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you more very
interesting thank you
nice to speak with a
intelligent
i appreciate that gang know somebody's
have deep thoughts about it appreciate
it thank you
you